are you able to identify anything you  don't like that donald trump has done  i don't know how much i'll agree with  him on letting the inmates out of the  prisons mm-hmm  which uh uh which inmates are those  which are which inmates are those  you know how they let a lot of the uh uh  prisons out by saying that they were  there because they sold pot or  their crime wasn't  bad enough to keep them in prison some  kind of dumb stuff like that you don't  like that how much i support that  because i haven't had time to really  look into that i just feel that  if you do the crime you should do the  time and it doesn't matter what color  you are right i'm in total support of  that